باذن ما بين ايديهم وما يعطوني
امين
يا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد الوجيس في
كتاب الطهاره
next
فطره
‏ex
to
hy and
the mentions is
awa and awa translates to brushing the
teeth that's really what a sewa is it is
not necessarily
brushing the
عود الاراك
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
رضي الله عنهم
that
any
of
the act of
and if persones te even toothbrush
without anything
they haveulfilled
يقول المؤلف السواك مستحب في كل حال
ويتاكد استحبابه
ثم ذكر خمسه مواطن
any
‏isally
isally enourag in theollowing
times
he then mentions
times throughout the day and night that
a person would use awa that he would
brush his tee and this is based on the
prophet's
‏first when
any person makes
it becable
that before
they use that brush te
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لولا ان اشق على امتي لامرتم بالسواك مع
الوضوء
والحديث عند الامام احمد في مسنده
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏How much more would that make to run a
brush across a person's tee every time
that a person makes?
Well, it is going beond what is
absolutely necessary for a person prayer
to be valid.
‏is add and if to comm tocribes
سنه
وما جعل عليكم في الدين من حرج
‏have some
more
عن
‏I would ‏M.